from the daily wire it says the editor
of the leading medical journey journal
the landsat which embroiled itself in
controversy when it referred to women as
bodies with vaginas
on the cover of one of its september
issues apologized monday for causing
offense but chose to defend the obtuse
phrasing use of the publication
uh the the weekly medical journal called
women bodies with vaginas in an article
titled periods on display for the
september 1st issue the quote
historically the anatomy and physiology
of bodies with vaginas have been
neglected and was featured on the cover
but the landsat was met with criticism
from many who argued that the journal
was itself marginalizing women by
referring to them in such a strange
manner
um
and there was some pushback against that
and that's that's reasonable pushback
there should be pushback and this is
what richard horton the editor-in-chief
this is what he said the lancet strives
for maximum
maximum inclusivity of all people in its
vision for advancing health in this
instant instance we have conveyed the
impression that we have dehumanized and
marginalized women those who read the
landsat regularly will understand that
this would never have been our intention
i apologize to our readers who are
offended by the cover quote and the use
of those same words in the review at the
same time i want to emphasize that
transgender health is an important
dimension of modern health care but one
that remains neglected trans people
regularly face stigma discrimination
exclusion and poor health often
experiencing difficulties accessing
proper health care um and then he went
on so he he
allegedly apologized but then went on of
course to defend
his uh the phrasing of bodies with
vaginas he says that people have accused
us of dehumanizing women
um
that's exactly what you've done
more so than that it's it's kind of a
deep it's a de-personing
you know you're you're treating
women as if they are not whole complete
persons
but rather as you say just
bodies with vaginas
this this for
for decades right this supposedly has
been the mission of
feminism and the mission of the left
supposedly
was to was to militate against this kind
of dehumanizing objectification of women
i mean can you imagine in a different
context even just a few years ago or
even today if it was in a different
context
and someone said ah you know women
they're just bodies with vaginas
if it was some let's say some womanizing
man who was accused of being a sexist
so what does it matter they're just
bodies with vaginas that's how i'm
treating them
that would be seen as totally utterly
dehumanizing and of course that's
exactly what it is if you enjoyed this
video be sure to give it a thumbs up and
share it with all your friends